so you're from Sudan you recently lived
in South Sudan when you finish this the
journalism program here in Berkeley
where are you going to go back to and
what do you hope to do I'll go back to
the Sudan's so go back to stands a sedan
my idea is to establish a film training
center that trainees will you know go
across you know their areas like if
insulin people go cross run just looking
for stories to tell at the same for
South Sudan and share these stories
together and they know just have that
kind of discussion going have people
talking about what we were and what are
we now just hoping to create bridge
between the two countries so you see
journalism and filmmaking as a tool of
dialogue and reconciliation definitely
you'll never you know connect with
people as you will experience their
stories and I see film is it's a way to
experience somebody else's story
where do you think the greater
misunderstanding takes place how the
west and the rest of the world sees the
Sudan's as you say or how the Sudan see
each other I'm more concerned about how
we see ourselves like how Sudan and
South Sudan see each other I mean this
is a huge gap I used a huge mistrust
between the two regions for long and
that resulted in so many a war that
lasted for more than 22 years but the
people they share so much they share a
long history they share like cultures
I've been in South Sudan for the past 10
years and people still asleep listening
to like two slow knees music oxidants
videos people still follow a hill on or
near if these are a favorite trainees
team like you go to Sudan the same thing
it was so listening to Abraham ding or
to trace out to be on call to all these
kind of South Sudanese singers and this
huge history of us as the Sudan together
and now that these two countries yes the
technicality is two countries but like
I've experienced living in both
countries and it's never different the
same so if you fast forward a few years
from now you're back in the Sudan's
either one of them at what point will
you know your dream has been realized
I'm personally hoping for for a united
to run again but I'll settle for a
healthy relationship between the two
country also for a bridge of dialogues
and of conversations and relationship
between the two cases and I want to
achieve that through you know creating
documentary films that you know speaks
to the people from the from the two
countries
you